[Music]
it is time now for a CBS deals this morning
we have a few things that may make your day
go just a bit smoother with these Time Savers
for the new year and all at exclusive low prices
so start shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen or visit cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert
Ashley Bellman joins us with more good morning
good morning Happy New Year 2023 the year of ease
ease yeah we need some means okay so starting
with this product this is the Limitless phone
station and cup cargo two different items this one
is 19.99 this one's 27.99 this you put into your
cup holder in your car hook your phone on there so
you can navigate safely this one is the cup holder
and it holds those big giant coffee cups that
ever fit in the car like ours like a set mode
Christmas gift yes super adjustable the savings
up to 30 33 percent off and I love this because
it's going to fit your big phone even in that big
case both items because if you use one you can't
use it for the other it's perfect exactly and you
can change it horizontally vertically however and
it's higher super yeah and also all the gunk
that gets in that car holder you don't get
that here okay oh I need I need a manicure okay
this is for all of my DIY girls who are great at
painting their toenails at home don't want to take
that trip to the salon this is called Salon step I
never paint my nails at home because I can never
find a comfortable position Now problem solved
okay this you put your foot on here you can adjust
it to your liking you have a little gel insert so
it's comfortable for your foot magnifying glass
LED light fan spot for your nail polish I mean
we never have to go to the salon again this is a
game changer it is Comfort it is ease and I mean
truly for 20.99 40 off think of all the money
that you're saving not having to go if nothing
else your daughter or your son might love it yes
it's just to have fun yes okay so finally grocery
shopping you know when you go to the grocery store
and it's just first of all plastic bands are in
effect in most of the country we like this we love
this if not plastic free is the way to be this is
the Lotus trolley bag it comes with these bags
you put them in your cart you can stay organized
grocery shopping one of them is insulated you
can make sure and especially checking out that
you put all the things that go in the pantry in
the one bag you put all the things that go in the
refrigerator in the other bag there's a slot for
your wine there's a slot for your eggs there's a
produce bag these bags are beautiful they're
washable you could actually take the bars out
and throw them in the washing machine use them as
totes this you will never forget at home because
they are so lovely to use is an optical illusion
or do they get smaller with the card as you go
they adjust yes yes they start smaller they've
got everything and I just want to show you how you
just can easily look with the insulation this is
incredible my husband's actually the one who does
the grocery shopping in the house and he is going
to be obsessed oh my gosh so how much again this
is 34.99 for everything for all of them 42 off
yes and you get the produce bags too and I love
that yeah yeah that's I mean and the thought of
it all pocket for your book so if you're waiting
in line nobody reads in the grocery store little
magazine you never know nobody like I said I don't
know thank you so much Ashley
of course we partner with all
of these companies to get these great
deals so to buy anything you saw today
scan that QR code on your screen
or head on over to cbsdeals.com